hey youtubers it's Charlie so there's a
big stuff going on a game of Thrones
tonight this is just going to be an R +
L equals J tower of joy explainer video
so careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far
especially episode 2 happy Mother's Day
to everyone we're gonna have to rename
this happy R + L equals J Day which is
also Mother's Day so nice coincidence it
almost looks like the universe is lining
things up in a neat little row important
stuff first if you've never heard of R +
L equals J I'd be very surprised but it
means Rhaegar Targaryen had a baby with
Lyanna Stark and that baby was Jon Snow
R + L equals J why does it matter who
Jon Snow's mother is well there are two
big reasons one he's going to be a very
important figure in the war against the
White Walkers in order to do that in
order to help him Melisandre needs to
use King's blood so if Jon Snow has
King's blood in him via Rhaegar
Targaryen her magic will be much more
powerful now noble blood not quite the
same thing as King's blood you could
also argue that the Starks were kings of
winter during the time of the first men
so by any measure if Jon Snow is the son
of Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna stark he
has some Kings blood in him which is
very important on a supernatural level
the second big reason that it's
important that he be the son of a
Targaryen is for the idea of the
Targaryen restoration that he has a
certain amount of legitimacy in the eyes
of the nobility of Westeros Varys is
talking a lot about a Targaryen
restoration because he has zero faith in
the current leadership House Baratheon
which is technically House Lannister
because of all the twincest so way back
in season five when Varys said they
needed a strong candidate that the
people would rally behind and like and
had legitimacy he was talking about
Daenerys specifically but if Jon Snow
was also a Targaryen and as they imply
in the teaser for episode 3 people think
that he's some sort of God because he
came back from the dead he would also be
a very strong candidate it would be easy
to get people to rally behind him so
that's why R + L equals J is important
in addition to being amazing fan service
the theory itself is pretty old book
readers have had it since the first book
came out a long long time ago it
involves a couple big events a couple
prophecies and stories that people have
told Rhaegar Targaryen is described in
the books as a firm believer in the
prince that was
almost prophecy what that says is that
there is a promise leader that will come
and help usher them from darkness so
they're talking about the long night in
this case the long night is coming
there's this mythical prince that's
going to come along and save them from
the long night his coming is said to be
heralded by a red comet which actually
appears in the sky the night Daenerys
Burns Khal Drogo so a lot of people
think that Daenerys is the prince who
was promised in Rhaegar just a
misinterpreted agender but all of his
actions his life or at least later in
his life were meant to bring about the
prophecy so that's why a lot of people
think that he sought Leon a stark out as
the fulfillment of the prophecy to have
a child with her the other part of the
prophecy is that that prince will have a
song it'll be a Song of Ice and Fire the
novels of Game of Thrones are called
a Song of Ice and Fire that's the name
of the entire saga even though the TV
shows only called Game of Thrones
Daenerys kind of gets a peek into this
prophecy when she's in the house of the
undying but they didn't really do it on
the TV show she sees her brother Rhaegar
Targaryen with his wife Elia Martell
nursing a baby named Aegon he says to
them this was the prince who was
promised and his is the Song of Ice and
Fire and then in the vision Rhaegar
turns and looks at Daenerys so it gets
kind of spooky and says the dragon has
three heads picks up a harp and starts
to play now the big point of contention
in the fandom is the interpretation of
the prophecy because we know Melisandre
thought that she saw visions she
misinterpreted them she thought that
Stannis was azor Ahai she was completely
wrong so a recurring theme in Game of
Thrones is that characters always
misinterpret prophecies what was Jon
Snow doing the night that the red comet
came that was actually the night that he
was going to the wall so another very
important event in the history of
Westeros implied leader in the war for
the dawn heading to begin his watch the
same night that Daenerys becomes
Daenerys unburnt so no matter who you
think the prince who was promised is you
have two really important figures two
really important leadership figures
taking their first steps towards their
larger destiny the next big event that
they have discussed on the TV show the
TV show doesn't always discuss all the
the r plus l equals j prince who was
promised prophesies stuff that happens
in the books for the tourney at
Harrenhal
was this massive massive tournament it
was believed to have been organized by
rhaegar targaryen
as an excuse to get all the Lords of the
kingdom together to rally against his
father the Mad King
Rhaegar himself won and crowned Lyanna
stark queen of beauty with a crown of
blue roses which was this big scandal
because he was already married to Elia
Martell in Liana had been promised to
Robert Baratheon
this was the story that Littlefinger
told to Sansa in the crypts during
season five as he was getting ready to
abandon her to Ramsay snow the reason
it's important for R + L equals J is
that it just sets president for Rhaegar
being interested in Lyanna Stark in that
he cared about her and did not steal her
away in rape her is a lot of people
believed not long after the tournament
Rhaegar with the help of Kingsguard
Arthur Dayne and a couple of the people
absconded with Lyanna stark setting
certain wheels in motion that led to
Robert's rebellion there are a number of
different reasons Robert's rebellion
happened in the Kingdom rallied against
the Mad King the abduction of Lyanna
stark was just a small part of that they
didn't learn till later that he had
taken her to the Tower of joy which we
don't really know why he called it the
Tower of joy but the idea is that it
represents something very happy for him
Robert's rebellion starts then after the
sack of King's Landing Ned Stark goes
with Howland Reed and a couple of his
other friends to try and rescue Lyanna
stark at the Tower of joy so the tower
of joy lyanna stark's death happened at
the very end of Robert's rebellion the
timeline between her abduction and when
Ned Stark arrived at the Tower of joy is
enough time for a baby to come to term
some more supporting evidence from the
timeline Daenerys his brother told her
that their other brother Rhaegar
remember Rhaegar was Daenerys oldest
brother was unhappy in his marriage to
Elia Martell as we know Robert very
unhappy in his marriage to Cersei so he
had all kinds of bastards all over the
place so for a gar lovely on a stark
it's not unheard of that they would have
a bastard together but Lyanna stark is
also quoted as saying that Robert would
never be true to anyone so she didn't
really love Robert Baratheon
even though Robert Baratheon himself
loves her greatly the reason they can't
travel to the tower joy and present day
to find any more evidence
or anything that's left over is because
Ned destroyed it later so as she lay
dying the story goes that she extracted
a promise from Ned Stark promise me Ned
those were her last words we don't know
what the promise is but because he found
her in a pool of blood as if she'd just
given childbirth she secretly made him
promise to protect the baby who is Jon
Snow so what we do know is that at the
end of the war Ned Stark comes home to
Catelyn Stark who has been married to
him they've had a child Robb Stark
together who's about Jon Snow's age so
Ned Stark shows up with this bastard
baby but never really explains to
Catelyn what happened so Callan just
assumes that Jon Snow is his bastard and
he was unfaithful to her so growing up
she wasn't outright vicious to Jon but
she also wasn't warm she was a very cold
mother to him but true to his word Ned
Stark never spoke of Jon Snow's mother
what happened at the Tower of joy what
he saw to anyone the only other person
that's still alive that we know is still
alive from that event is Howland Reed
but the TV show hasn't done him and if
you don't know who Howland Reed is he is
Mira's father Meera and Jojen father and
I know a lot of people are wondering why
did Ned never tell Jon Snow who his
mother was
well the idea is is that because his
birth was so controversial that he was
the son of one of the enemies of the
kingdom one of Roberts enemies that if
Robert were to ever learn Jon Snow's
true parentage he would smash his head
in with his great war hammer remember
with the mountain admitted to doing too
baby
Aegon picking up tiny baby Aegon and
smashing his head against the wall so
the idea is that maybe Ned didn't want
that to happen to Jon Snow so that's why
he hid the secret for so long so why is
it so important that the TV show is
doing a tower of joy flashback in
episode three why would the three-eyed
Raven take brand they're not just for
fanservice but because it's giving us
the origin of a very important character
now that doesn't mean that will actually
see a baby Jon Snow they might not
explain it literally we might not even
get to go inside the Tower of joy to see
we might just see Ned Stark walk out
with a baby it remains to be seen just
brace yourself for disappointment in
case they don't fully explain R plus L
equals J but there are just been a
number of times that the TV show has
tried to give you hints that Rhaegar was
a very good person
like Barristan Selmy telling Daenerys
that her brother really loved to play
music he was very kind to his people he
was not the murderer and rapist that
Robert Baratheon made him out to be we
also saw in brans flashback in Episode
two that Lyanna stark was a total badass
very free-willed probably even a good
fighter so it's not like somebody could
take her against her will if she didn't
want to be with them so it's almost like
the show is creating the circumstances
to give you hints that are plus l equals
J but let me know in the comments do you
think that they are actually going to do
our plus L equals J on the TV show and
even if they don't fully explain it like
we don't get to go inside the Tower of
joy I mean do you think that that is
what the show is trying to tell us
because Melisandre really needs that
King's blood John would have to be half
Targaryen in order to have King's blood
and he'd have to have a legitimate claim
to the throne in order to get the
backing of the other noble houses of
Westeros because no matter how special E
is if the other Nobles of Westeros that
control all the combined armies of the
kingdom don't want to support him then
he's not going to get the men that he
needs to fight the White Walkers
eventually like it's implied that
Daenerys bringing her army from the east
even if she's able to unite the entire
eastern continent and bring them to
Westeros it's not going to be enough to
fight the White Walkers so hopefully
they will just start lining things up in
a perfect little row starting with this
episode but if you thought that Jon Snow
coming back to life in episode 2 was a
big WTF moment you haven't seen anything
yet this is when things are starting to
get really exciting this is only the
beginning of holy-shit moments this
season so be sure to subscribe to get my
video tonight there's a new round of the
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video it's just a $20 Amazon gift
card I'll just remind everyone when I
post my episode 3 video later tonight
while you guys wait for my video to post
tonight you can click here for all my
Captain America Civil War Easter eggs
and you can click here for all my
episode videos from season 6 so far
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you